STILL LOSE.
IN THE LAST GAMES.
THEY WILL FINISH YOUR CHECK IN
GOES TO THE POINT.THE SIDE
OF THE NET.ATE WOULD
WATCH THE SKATE.
UP AGAINST THE POST BUT
ANOTHER CHANCE THEY SCORE AGAIN.
THE STICK AND HE REACHES
FOR A.ANSWER BACK MAKE
NOBODY IS GOING TO MOVE
COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
MIDDLE AND A BACKHANDER AND HE
SCORES.
CAPITALS LEAD IT, 3-1.PLAYER JU
CUTS RIGHT IN.
BY THE TIME
A4-ONE. JENSEN WAS ALL ALONE.A
MOVED UNTIL THE PUCK WAS BY
HIM.
>>
48 TO GO.
IT TAKES THE SHOP.
COULDN'T GET A
DOWN IN
CHECKS THE PUCK.
THORTON,
LOMBERG.   THERE.
DUGOUT THEREBYMONTOUR.
AND HUBERDEAU BLEEDS GOAL.
THE SHORTYTHE LEGS.
HERE HE COMES THE OTHER WAY
SHORTHANDED.
PUTS IT IN FRONT.HE
COMMITTED HIMSELF.
CAME BACK THE OTHER WAY.HAVE TI
IT DID.
EITHER WAY, THERE IS ON THE SHO
SIDE.
WE HAVE A GOOD LOOK AT IT.
THIS IS WHAT HEHE